[Music]
this is never before seen footage from 9
11 that has just appeared online never
before back what i said how do you feel
about this right why did it take so long
yeah ryan is this is this going to make
you cry
or will tifa longheart kissing uh
[ __ ] cloud make you cry harder you
piece of [ __ ]
i don't know i'm just kidding is this
about jet fuel burning steel
conspiracy
why did it take so long
wait can i guess what it is okay yes i
swear to god i've never seen this i
guess what i've always imagined seeing
which would be horrifying is the plane
coming through
the building
no okay no no it's not that okay but
this is for not for the faint of heart
especially if you have an emotional
attachment to 9 11 straight up okay
he doesn't
[Applause]
i'm gonna fast forward just a little bit
[ __ ] dude
[Applause]
first plane is already hit
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you never see that [ __ ] oh my lord
that's [ __ ] insane
oh my god and all my lords
that's crazy
i like that one guy wow is this
terrorism
is that what they said that's what i
just heard yeah the guy did say that i
thought i was hearing it but steve heard
it too
wow yeah so never before seen video
yeah before seeing videos showing the
second plane he's trying to cry he's
trying to cry
i'm not a good enough actor
maybe we don't have enough mana
on september 11th has just been uploaded
online and provides a horrifying angle
of the devastating attack that
literally during a 911 article and uh
just in case you can't do the math it's
been more than 20 years since this
terrorist attack
and this video literally just went up
about a uh february 24th so about a week
ago wow
where were you i was in fourth grade
fourth grade
class
[ __ ] child holy [ __ ] i remember we
watched on the tv they pulled it out and
then we sat there and we were all like
watching it and then we left we went
home after did you know anything about
like doing towers yet or anything no i
just knew that like it was a terrorist
attack
just like what that guy said
and like every i just remember everyone
was just really sad that's what i
remember and i remember like seeing all
the firefighters and like all the
montages they did but that was pretty
much it that's all i really remember so
not much like you know i was in high
school me too and i i was in my
girlfriend's [ __ ] at the time
i had to get one in the morning nine in
the morning
right no it was at six in the morning on
our side that's the horniest sec machine
thank you i remember yeah first first
period was uh p
i always got first peer p so i don't
have to do no work you know
walked in
everyone's in the gymnasium just like on
the [ __ ] bleachers they had three
four tvs just like rolled in and then
everyone was just watching it and in
every [ __ ] class after that people
were just watching the tv
yeah that was pretty where were you
i was in high school i was i i remember
it
very
um
yeah i remember very accurately because
we were in my like ap psychology class
which had recently been taken over by
the baseball coach
ap psychology was being but okay he was
really smart though you don't know i'm
all surprised no he was versus no no he
was he was he was how did he part that
but
i don't know man did he use uh pitching
you for you from
sports psychology yeah what we need is a
reaction hey man if rain is like a
baseball mitt there's like a thumb
i don't know where i'm going with this
um
but
i remember i remember he like yeah he
pulled up the tv and he was just like
distraught right and he was just like
the most like just like all-american
white dude i mean baseball coach um but
i remember this like so specifically
because like the first half of that year
me and him were like getting along so
well and i was like i was always like no
i was like class clown guy yeah whatever
i would always make jokes and he would
like riff back with me and it was like
funny right oh my god
god did he look at you be like
[ __ ] just just this one turn
like with your dad the remote in his
hand
no but
i remember specifically after that day
he wouldn't even look me in the eye for
the rest of that year he wouldn't talk
to me he would he like
if i like if i did make a joke he like
he sent me out of the room a couple
times i was like what the [ __ ] just
happened like i [ __ ] this rule yeah no
he sucked he's not very smart this guy
yeah yeah he's also a [ __ ] yeah were
you also striking out incessantly during
psychology
sucked at baseball that's all it is
guys like he sucks at baseball he's just
[ __ ] good
he was so funny in the beginning when he
was on the bench
hit him with the pitch
[Laughter]
you hit a home run then i look you in
the eye
serious question um did you know
especially not just from him but like
after 9 11 like did you undergo any like
weird other circumstances that were just
[ __ ] up well i'm like i'm from
huntington beach so it's like oh [ __ ]
pretty nazi out there
pretty naughty out there like they have
like a kkk rally and stuff not for real
dude i ran into real real white
supremacists like people talk about why
it's surprising i'm like man that's like
some suggested white supremacy me and my
buddies were at the beach with dudes
that had swastika tattoos that just
straight up wanted to fight like that's
some real [ __ ] out there this is the way
they did the white lives matter
[ __ ] american history x city dude
they don't [ __ ] around curry marsh
but i love bodyboarding there and
there's an amazing dog beach so there's
a great dog beach they don't stop me
from the dog beach yeah no no no
they can't tread on our dog beach
but yeah it's it's it's crazy because
it's still southern california but it's
like yeah this [ __ ] nazi capital in
huntington beach but like i mean no one
like tried to like beat me up or
anything but like my my parents were
like threatened outside our house one
time like
it's it it's just
there's so many stupid people yeah you
guys like where are they other side of
the world
hey dude there's a lot of that stupids
going on with russians right now they're
talking about expelling russians from
the united states
taking russians rounding them up into
[ __ ] internment camps and [ __ ]
they're actually i've heard people
mentioning this [ __ ] online i heard that
a lot of people were like we're not
gonna go to russian restaurants anymore
and i'm like what the [ __ ] does that
have to do
like with i'm like name a russian
wrestler
actually yeah first off which is russian
salad dressing that's all you got neymar
russian food
oh that's that's too that's a weird joke
huh well i just don't know where it
comes from i love sushi and but the only
sushi that they have there for some
reason is things like philadelphia rules
and california rules they don't have
like regular cities in russia russia in
russia that's too meta dude traveling
man that's traveling man's humor but
that's that's cool though i didn't know
that yeah yeah shout out to russians
comment below if that's true something's
super [ __ ] up with 9 11 related and i
will shed a tear for this
steve
[Laughter]
i was at the time it happened i was
going to cerritos community college
and then uh how many community college
did you go to i transferred a lot
all right you want to try out different
schools wipe my record clean a lot i was
uh i remember seeing it in the morning
and then i went to school that day and
then when i got there like all the
teachers outside and they were like yeah
we're not doing school today because
there's a rumor that like la is next
what the [ __ ] there was like a thing
where like oh they're and i guess
somewhere in the whole thing there was a
plan for one of the planes to head to la
but it never made it what landmark do
you remember i don't know i have no idea
but then they go park the fountain
yes like where they're going la's a
tough place to staple center at the time
like how do you i don't know but they
sent everybody home and then uh i
remember once i finally came back to
school like i think like just three days
later there was this there's this really
nice guy that was in like a couple of my
classes he was this indian dude and he
was sick so he had the um
yeah and he was a super nice dude he was
the volunteer tutor for the disabled kid
who would attend class so he wasn't he
wasn't actually
[ __ ] he would take the class put a
scumbag or the disabled kid and help him
out
he's just super nice guy
some dudes beat him up in the parking
lot
after school
over 9 11. this indian dude disabled kid
too all people you know yeah you know
you know you know the school and he left
he left school because of that you know
the school you went to the sga right so
uh there was a seat guy that ran a
liquor store down the street and he got
shot after 9 11 because they basically
were like hey [ __ ] and then
yeah [ __ ]
stupid so see the temple that got shot
up by like that's because they don't
know the difference i mean that's the
whole thing even people who are muslims
like why would you attack muslims in
america they're here in america
most of the time they're fleeing like
the [ __ ] from exactly i mean that's
the same [ __ ] with the whole asian hate
thing right it's like you know everyone
they think every asian person is like
riddled with corona and they ruin their
lives that's different we did bring the
flu though that's different
speak for yourself don't edit that out
don't edit that
it's your fault yeah yeah
i was uh i was in zero period at the
time uh which because my sister went to
zero period and we're at the same high
school so i didn't have zero period but
we had the carpool so i'm sitting in the
library i'm always sitting the library
at like 6 30 in one year what the [ __ ]
and we had this librarian his name was
mr erskine i'll never forget the [ __ ]
earth skin earth
earth
skin
the globe on his own foreskin mr fortune
um
and you know i'm young and
impressionable and naive or whatever and
beautiful
amazing
rips
just
didn't matter that the micropenis was
there anyways um any and he literally
walks up to the table no context and his
most dramatic thing and he i'll never
forgets he goes
america may be at war
while he walks away
that's a librarian for sure
i was so [ __ ] confused because i was
like you're weird dude you know what i
mean but then literally you know that
you remember that day that day just
unfolded yeah yeah it wasn't just like a
moment and then like everybody on the
west coast just understood the context
it was like developing context slowly
and slowly right and then one period
after the next you'd walk in and the
teacher would be the same thing but hey
uh we're going to chill in the
curriculum today if everybody's cool
we're just going to put on the news and
as a kid right you're like [ __ ] yeah tv
you know you forget so messed up the
worst day for the princess bride again
fiddler on the roof he's watching the
same plane going the same tower like 89
times yeah dude actually yeah that's all
you did watch that a lot that's all it
was right and but but the second time i
hadn't hit at that time when we first
found out about it and i i believe it
wasn't until like first period right
that everybody on the west coast started
finding out about the second town and
that's when it became yeah yeah yeah
right because the first one was like
accident yeah it kind of has a small
plane too exactly when i left the house
it'd only just been one plane when i got
to school they were like dude it was two
yeah and then you found out about the
[ __ ] pentagon and then you're like
this is crazy and they said there was a
there was a plane head towards the white
house yeah there was they thought all
kinds of [ __ ] that three or whatever
right yeah and then did did all of that
[ __ ] totally
right destroy your brain once loose
change came out
loose change i didn't watch until
significantly later and that [ __ ] me
it [ __ ] everybody all the all the 911
conspiracy stuff i wasn't hip to that
[ __ ] until like maybe like two three
years later oh really is that what it
was such [ __ ] yeah immediately i was
like loose changes garbage so it's a
documentary naive i didn't oh you've
never seen loose i haven't seen loose
don't watch it now
is that the one where they talk about
building seven and like how that's a
mystery it talks about jet fuel burning
building seven had significant damage
because all the [ __ ] towers collapsed
around it right so the debris
no but really it had a huge amount of
rubble from all these towers collapsing
around it and then also there was fires
in like an entire
corner of the building like the entire
half of the building was on fire oh [ __ ]
so like it wasn't just like hey this
steel melts and stuck it's like no no
the the building was structurally
impacted by the other towers collapsing
and then also the fires is it some flat
earth [ __ ] for sure not not exactly i
get i get where people are coming from
with it but it's just less even in terms
of the demolition conspiracies yeah yeah
but when you see the pictures of
building seven on fire you can see like
the entire
back half of the building just
completely blasted with smoke it [ __ ]
and then the structural damage from the
towers collapsing around it it's just a
different story it's all this is a
different story yeah but but they're
like insinuating like massive grand
conspiracy which is
it's really
just detrimental to everything just the
same way
[ __ ]
what's it called
what what's the q anon q anon is just
yeah for sure [ __ ] up everything it's
a giant cult it's an online cult i don't
think it's that simple but i chance dude
they're pretty good they're pretty fun
so that so i think the truth out of all
of that which i believe is that
regardless if it was intentional or not
or orchestrated
the bush family and dick cheney
benefited from it so whether they took
an opportunity of a tragedy
to profit off of it or they orchestrated
it
i don't know but motives don't matter
because they profited from it well what
i believe
it very frankly is that like okay so
911 happened the fbi knew the 19
heinjackers were in the country they
were actually monitoring them they
didn't do anything nobody got picked up
nobody got questioned nobody got
anything that's the weird part it's
really weird because that's a fact so
was it just allowed to happen i don't
know that's it that's more interesting
than the loose change [ __ ] was you know
oh yeah yeah so would they manufacture
something to make it seem like a crazy
or a cruise missile hit the pentagon
it's like okay well maybe it wasn't
maybe it's not that complicated maybe
just they let them do it
and lose change what about the um but
why would they let them do it because
they profited
exactly what y'all said the whole uh
the drills that were going on during
that time that we're talking about oh
there's gonna be a turret yeah that's
weird that's definitely weird
that stuff was hella weird no because
they had a terrace drill for something
like that similarly like within the same
day right yeah it was the same day which
is why when alarms went off everybody
thought it was a drill so they weren't
responding that way
but they they are getting that like
terrorist intel all the time like the
chatter yeah they're hearing stuff all
the time but i will say they use the
same intelligence to claim that young
arabic men at the time
were
quote unquote joining
al-qaeda
and all they would do is take them for
questioning beat them constantly
all this [ __ ] yeah get them to admit a
bunch of [ __ ] they never did or
thought about
and then they go away for terrorism
meanwhile the united states citizen
average person goes yay good another
terrorist jailed and like meanwhile they
get no due process no no dan courtney no
nothing so do i believe the official
story ever not as much because of [ __ ]
like that
yeah i mean i'll never doubt like uh
a president and their whatever whoever
is empowered to take advantage of a
shitty situation which every oh yeah
they all do but like to like to
orchestrate something like that i think
is just so
unpredictable as to how it will play out
that like
to actually try and do it is is an
insane thing to take on right it's kind
of like well right now like with the
pandemic people say it was orchestrated
but i mean like
i don't know
if that's even possible but what i do
know is there are people who are
profiting off of it there's a lot of
people who profit off a tragedy they see
an opportunity and they swoop in and
they
you know it's usually people that have
power people have influence people who
have
large companies that can benefit from
this tragedy and time and time again it
happens so for me i'm like why like it's
happening apparently right in front of
our eyes why can't we look at that and
scrutinize
now i mean according to cfc even now the
kofi was probably a bio weapon right
that just that just got released within
48 hours right so
so now we're talking about like okay
well this was a conspiracy now it's
actually like maybe confirmed fact not
necessarily confirmed but like this was
maybe actually what what caused this